president of the Russian Federation
Vladimir Vladimir which Putin
thank you
dear citizens of Russian Federation
citizens of
DPR and LPR
Herson and zaparosia regions
members of Duma and senators of the
Russian Federation
as you know in Danish and Logan's people
Reserve public in Herson and zaparosia
region we had referendums
the results have come through and the
results are known
people have made their choice
and it's uh
definitive Choice today we are signing
the degree on accepting LPR DPR
zaparosia and her son region
I'm sure that the federal assembly will
support the laws of creating four new
regions of new four new subjects of the
Russian Federation because this is the
wheel of the millions of people
foreign
and of course this is their right their
uh
integral rate which is uh emphasized in
the principles of United Nations it's
the self-determination of people
it's uh the
um right that is based on the historical
Unity which was defended by generations
of our people people who for Generations
protected Russia
uh Romance of the world and ushakov
fought in Belarus
second and patomkin
fought and also our grandfathers and the
great grandfathers fought in the in the
uh Wars and
people who did not agree with the
military coup in 2014 people who
gave their lives for the right to to
keep their belief their language
it's the people of donbass these uh
victims of inhumane terrorist attacks
conducted by the Kiev regime Visa
peaceful citizens children
grandmothers Russians ukrainians people
of various ethnic Origins
and
and as yoga and Olga Natura and the
other Heroes of this uh
the Morgan
medev who was a a military who died
heroically all the heroes of the special
military operation they are heroes
the heroes of the great Russia
and we would like to keep observe a
minute of Silence
in their honor
thank you
the choice of millions of people of LPR
and DPR zaparosia and Herson regions
um what what's behind that is our common
history
despite all the difficulties they have
carried through this love for Russia and
this feeling cannot be exterminated by
anyone and that's why the older
generations and the younger people who
were born after the tragedy of the
destruction of the Soviet Union they
they wanted the unity
in 1991 in
um there was a decision
by representatives of the party of the
leading party to dissolve the United the
USSR
and this has created this has created uh
destroyed the connections between
different parts of our country and
um
the last heads of the Soviet Union
went against the will of the people of
uh of the Soviet Union and broke that
country into smaller countries they and
they just informed the people about that
without asking them and um we accept
that they probably did not understand
what they were doing and they did not
understand the consequences this would
lead to but this is not important
anymore Soviet Union is no longer there
we cannot return to the Past
and for Russia we don't need this
anymore
we're not aiming for that but there is
nothing
stronger than the decisive will of
millions of people who
um according to their culture to their
language believed to be part of Russia
they for Generations that lived in a
single country and there's nothing
stronger than the will of these people
to come back to the historic Route
for many years the people in donbass
were subjected to genocide and shelling
and in here soon they try to cultivate
hatred for Russia and lately Kiev regime
threatened death and Punishment to
teachers and they were threatening
repressions to the millions of people
who supported Russia but
people from LPR DPR and his son and
zaparoshi expressed their will
and
the real masters of Kiev regime in the
west uh need to remember this
people from hereson DPR LPR and
zapparoshi become our citizens forever
and we call upon Kiev regime she
immediately sees all military actions
and the war that they began back in 2014
and come back to the negotiation table
we are open to this and we stated that
many times but people of
Logan
donetskinson and zaparosa we will not
discuss these areas because they've made
their choice
foreign
authorities have to respect the
expression of the will of these people
and this is the only path to peace we
will protect our land using all our uh
forces and we will do everything to
ensure people's security and this is the
great liberating mission of our people
we will of course rebuild all destroyed
uh towns and we will build hospitals and
theaters and schools and we'll continue
developing infrastructure and and
Industry we will ensure Healthcare and
pension support and of course we will
increase levels of security we will do
everything for people in these regions
to feel the support of all republics and
all parts of this large motherland
foreign
colleagues I'd like to address the
soldiers and officers who are taking
part in special military operation to uh
Warriors of donbassy navarrosia who also
joining military after the partial
mobilization those who volunteered to
come to the recruitment centers I would
like to address their wives and children
I'd like to say why they're fighting
there who is the enemy that is against
us who is creating new Wars and crises
to to make profit out of them our
compatriots our brothers and sisters in
Ukraine part of our
people saw with their own eyes what the
leading circles in the west are
preparing for the uh people in the world
and they have expressed their true
nature in there
and
and we we will not
uh
um back in in 1991 the West
believed that USSR will not uh come back
or Russia will not come back from that
blow and we had this awful
1990s and however Russia withstood that
and
um became more powerful and
took its deserved place and it's but the
West is looking for new opportunities to
hit us
and they always dreamed about breaking
our state into smaller States who will
be fighting against each other
they are not they cannot be happy with
this idea that there's this large
country with all their riches natural
riches and the and people who will never
uh
live under foreign oppression
and they are
prepared to to do everything using this
neocolonial system to Rob all other
countries in the world
um and the whole Humanity has to pay
them uh some Jews
to this hegemon
and they've got this
cruel motivation and that's why they
they are very aggressive towards
independent states they're aggressive
towards Traditional Values in cultures
they are trying to undermine
International and integrational
processes and new centers of
technological development it is
critically important to them
so that all countries surrender their
sovereignty to the United States
voluntarily some countries voluntarily
agree to do this
and they voluntarily agree to become
vassals of these states
others are being destroyed
and bullied and after the this there are
millions of broken lives and
areas of uh social uh disturbance and so
on
uh they the only thing they want to have
is is their profit out of this their
greed their desire to to keep their
unrestricted power
this is the reason of this hybrid war
that the West is conducting against the
Russia
they want to see us a colony
they do not want to have a
a cooperation on the basis of equality
they want to Rob us
um
they to them our
philosophy is is a direct threat and
that's why they attempt to kill our
philosophers
and our development and now uh
um livelihood is a threat to them
they do not need Russia we need Russia
I'd like to remind you that
the ambition to for world domination has
been broken by Russian resistance many
times in the past and today we are
defeating defending our values and our
traditions
they believe that they will not be
punished for their actions
and the agreements in the area of
strategic cooperation uh are being
canceled
agreements on the state level
announced to be null and void
and the agreements that were there in
the past are being completely canceled
and the uh agreements on the
non-profileration of weapons uh
unilaterally
um canceled
who
what are these rules that they are
acting
um based on who saw those rules who
agreed upon those rules and we see that
there are double standards triple
standards they are just taking us for
fools
uh Russia is a great country and it's a
great civilization and it's not going to
continue to live under this false rules
it it's the West that broke that
principle of
um
of
of the borders and they are now
unilaterally deciding who has the right
to self-determination and who doesn't
why are they making that decision who
gave them the right to decide that
of
that's why they're very angry at the
choice of people in uh Crimea danesca
hereson
and zaparosa that's why they believe
that they people do not have the right
to have to self-determination the
hegemony
has got a character of
totalitarian nature and militarism
and they
and they believe that all these
countries have to be adjoined to the
list of Barbarians uh who need to be
fought against and oppressed
there's nothing new in this
the Western Elites have always been like
this they have been colonizers and they
remain colonizers they discriminate and
they they distinguish between the first
class of Nations and second-class
Nations we never
believed that and that's why there is
this rosophobia that is being spread all
over these countries
the Western countries believe that their
civilization and they're near Liberal
culture is the golden standard to
everyone else
this is sounds quite strange
um even the
uh the Western Elites even believe that
uh their own sins have to be accepted by
everyone else
we need to remind the West that
near Colonial politics
began in the Middle Ages and then they
robbed India Africa and there were Wars
against China
where they had to surrender their ports
for opium trade what they did
um subject to the whole Nations to to
drug abuse and to
um other things and they they
were effectively hunting people
and we we are proud of the fact that in
the 20th century it was our country
which was the head of the anti-colonial
movement and allowed these nations
independent development and Conquer
um diseases
and hunger
and one of the reasons for rucifobia and
this Anger from the Western Elites is is
to do with the fact that we did not
allow them to Rob this formerly Colonial
countries further and this was achieved
by the fact that we were able to create
a strong independent state which
continued to strengthen on the basis of
strong values of
of Christianity Islam
and other religions
it's known that
there were plans of intervention in
Russia and at the beginning of 17th
century and
thank you
and this these plans
failed
and all of this was achieved in at the
end of 20th century when the state
collapsed and they pumped out trillions
of dollars from this country using
various schemes we did not forget
anything in these days in danetsky and
Logan and zaparosia people
spoke about their desire to restore our
historic Unity thank you
Western countries
for centuries have been talking about
the
uh their desire to bring democracy to
other countries and this is completely
opposite it's pressure and oppression
and slavery and violence
and this wood World Order is
undemocratic and is uh void of Liberty
U.S is a country that uh used uh nuclear
weapons twice
um
Nagasaki in Hiroshima were the towns
they were attacked by
um and they they ruined all these uh
cities in Hamburg and Colin in Germany
without any military need just to
demonstrate without any military need
necessity and the carpet bombed on these
cities in order to
threaten the whole world and our
country and the carpet bomb bombed uh
Vietnam and used chemical weapons and up
to this day they are occupying Korea
Japan and Germany in fact
and they are talking about them as
um
um as their partners
as their allies
and we can see that the the first people
the first leaders of these countries are
being listened to they bug their
offices and also their homes
and
and we can see that these countries just
accept that
and
they are
they're developing chemical weapons and
and
experiment on people and they believe
this to be Noble causes
and they provoked
today's
large movement Immigration Movement
through their actions
now they are transporting
wheat out of Ukraine where is it going
under the pretext of ensuring food
security for the for the poorest
countries where is it actually going
it's going to Europe maybe five percent
less than five percent goes to the
poorest countries
again this is just fooling and deceit
American Elites in essence are using
the tragedy of these people in order to
weaken their competitors in order to
to to conquer the national States and
this goes for other countries France
Spain Italy and so on and there
Washington is asking for more and more
sanctions and majority of European
leaders
simply agree to this they understand
that America is pushing for complete
cutoff of
Russian energy to EU
in order to capture the European market
themselves the European Elites
understand all of that themselves but
they prefer to just submit to these
demands and this is just a betrayal of
their people of their own people
but Anglo-Saxons are not happy with the
sanctions they moved to
to terrorist attacks having arranged the
explosions on the pipelines gas
pipelines in in the sea and they are
destroying the European infrastructure
it's all clear who benefits from this
the dictat of the United States is based
on on sheer power
but it's wrapped into this pretense of
international law and principles
and that's why there are hundreds and
hundreds of military bases and attempts
to further expand NATO and create new
military alliances
and they're actively working on uh in
strengthening the connection between
Washington and Tokyo and they uh
and anyone who is daring to challenge
the
hegemon is automatically
declared the pariah
in
the new Colonial plans
are presented by the West uh
in the form of
of
trying to contain other countries
but what that actually means is um
undermining any Sovereign centers we
talked about containment we know about
containment of Iran China and other
countries
we we know that the current partners and
current allies of the us we know that
whenever whenever the U.S doesn't like
something they introduce sanctions
against their allies or partners
this is what's happening in in practice
and this will continue
in the crosshairs they've got everyone
including our closest neighbors CIS
countries
they are
they started the
sanctioned blitzkriek against Russia and
they thought that they would order the
whole world around uh using that however
not everyone is excited about that
we see that
political
masochists and other uh
people who liked these non-traditional
political relations
they they
refused to cooperate with Russia
uh and uh
we see that uh the Western the West has
the habit of uh brute force and trying
to capture everything
but that then they are frozen in the
past
and this
creates the this concept of
exceptionalism
but it also creates the culture of
information
uh starvation in the west they have
drowned the truth using very aggressive
uh propaganda like herbals
and they say that the larger the deceit
the the more people will believe it
um they are printing money but you can't
feed anyone with this money
you cannot warm your homes with this
money
what's very important is what we just
said you cannot
you cannot feed people with this printed
money you need to have food
and there's inflated
capitalizations will not be able to feed
anyone either
you need to have actual food
so politicians in Western Europe have to
persuade their citizens to shower less
to eat less and warm and put on warm
clothes
and those who disagree with this are
announced as radicals
and they always point to Russia saying
this is the source of your troubles and
I would like to emphasize that there is
the basis to believe that Western Elites
are not going to look for any ways out
of Current financial and food crisis
which happened due to their own fault
their fault that they conducted the to
the actions that they've been conducting
over the last few years
and
they are not going to resolve problems
of
uh
Injustice
and they are going to steer towards
their usual recipes
we see that the crisis of the beginning
of the 20th century was resolved through
the first World War
and we see that the U.S
after because after going into recession
was able to impose the Dollar on the
rest of the world
and we see that the crisis has become
more acute in the 70s or 80s of the last
century
and we see that they have used and
abused the resources of the
disintegrated Soviet Union
and now they have their goal to break
Russia at any cost
and they want to rob people of their
riches to plug their own holes
and they will if this if they succeed
they will try to lead the whole system
into complete collapse
and they will try to write it off with a
war Russia understands its responsive
responsibility to International
Community
and it's obvious that today's
neo-colonial model
is doomed but I would like to emphasize
that the real Masters will continue to
fight to the end they've got nothing
else to offer apart from keeping that
racketeering and robbing model that
they've stuck to
and
today
they are
moving to radical
radical attack on
basic values of family and uh and so on
I would like to address all citizens of
the country not not just those who are
in this audience I'd like to address
everyone in Russia do we want here in
Russia in this country
do we want uh father and mother to be
replaced by parent number one parent
number two are they crazy
do we want in our schools right from the
early age so the children are uh being
um
uh advertised all these uh sexual
um deviations and so on and where
they're offered to change their
gendering and so on do we want any of
that for our country
none of that is acceptable to us we have
our own future
the dictator of Western Elites is aimed
at subjugation of of people of their own
countries too
everyone complete
denial of uh
of people's rights and they are moving
towards towards the open satanism
uh
and uh Jesus said that you will see uh
people uh you know you'll see the people
by their actions
and
we see that
um new centers of development are being
formed now and they represent the
majority of humanity
and they are prepared not just to
present an alternative but also to
defend their own sovereignty and gain
true Liberty and historic perspective
the right to their own development and
into their own harmonious life
we've got a lot of people who support us
in including in the US and we feel their
support in various
societies and countries
we have the movement that is being
developed now that is developing uh
anti-colonial Freedom Movement
and this is the power that will
determine the future political reality
dear friends today we are fighting for
just an Freedom path for ourselves for
Russia
uh for
dictator and uh
imposing of the will is left in the past
that
um
nothing should be based on somebody's
exceptionalism on suppression of other
cultures and countries
we have to turn over this page
the the
destruction of this Western hegemony is
irreversible the world will never be the
same
and we're called by the by this history
by by our faith
to fight for historic Russia
for great historic Russia for future
generations for our
children and grandchildren we need to
protect them from this horrible
experiments which are aimed to break
their soul and their consciousness
we are fighting for
our culture for our language so that
it's impossible to just cancel it and
and remove it from history we have to
consolidate the whole society
and the basis for this unification can
only be can only lie in Integrity in
Freedom
and our compassion for people are the
basic values that unify this
Evan Alexandra irian is a true patriot
if I believe my motherland to be Russia
that means I
I
think in Russian I sing in Russian and I
believe in spiritual power of Russian
people and my
spirit and its Spirit my spirit
there
the suffering of the people is my
suffering and the the development of
these people is my development
so these words
um
uh highlight the principle which was
followed by many generations of Russians
and it's especially relevant today
the choice was made by people from LPR
and DPR and her son and zaparosia they
made their choice to be with their
people to be with motherland
to to follow its uh Faith a path and to
win
and the truth is with us
the Russia is behind us
foreign
of signing of documents is about to
begin
the president of the Russian Federation
Vladimir Vladimir is Putin
head of the danette's People's Republic
Denise
vadimir pushilin
head of logansk People's Republic
foreign
oblast
Vladimir vasilevic salder
assigning the agreements between the
Russian Federation and
danielska People's Republic
Russian Federation and
logansk
People's Republic
Russian Federation and
zaparrojia
region
Russian Federation and
Kirsten region
agreements on accepting
into the Russian Federation of the
nielsk People's Republic
ansk People's Republic
foreign
region
and
hearson region
and
foaming as part of the Russian
Federation
of new subjects
national anthem of the Russian
Federation
is being played